un extrait de l'adaptation américaine
des romans millénium le premier des
trois tombes en fait millenium vous
savez c'est cette saga policière
suédoise qui s'est vendu à 75 millions
d'exemplaires et bien désormais il y en
aura un quatrième
mais c'est sous la plume d'un autre
auteur maxence bilodeau david la guerre
craintes c'est le romancier suédois qui
a écrit la suite de la saga millénium
humble de nature il dit qu'il était
terrifiée à l'idée de succéder à stieg
larsson energy services
il en est venu à bout voici son livre
500 pages qui sortira demain à près de
trois millions d'exemplaires dans 25
pays
les personnages principaux qu'on a aussi
connu au cinéma s'y retrouve
la mystérieuse lisbeth salander pirate
informatique aux mille talents et le
journaliste dans kate michael blomkvist
de mais on sera tous deux les tricks du
nouveau livre mais aujourd'hui tout ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'il y est notamment
question de l' agence nationale de
sécurité américaine et que selon
l'auteur le monde a plus que jamais
besoin de lisbeth salander l'histoire de
stieg larsson qui a écrit les trois
premiers livres est un roman en soit il
est mort d'une crise cardiaque en 2004
avant même que ses livres soient publiés
larsson n'avait pas fait testament alors
sa conjointe de toujours eva gabrielsson
avec qui il n'était pas marié n'a
absolument rien toucher les millions
qu'on produit les livres et les films
sont allés au père et au frère de
larsson maintenant millionnaire
on rapporte que cette fois ils auraient
décidé de verser leur part des bénéfices
au magazine suédois expo cofondée par
stieg larsson un magazine qui combat le
racisme et l'extrémisme
un quatrième livre millénium donc écrit
par un auteur différent
c'est rare mais ça arrive plusieurs
james bond ont été écrits par d'autres
auteurs après la mondiale fleming c'est
le cas aussi des robert ludlum ou des
san antonio
écrit par le fils de frédéric dard dans
tout cela
la veuve larsson n'aurait peut-être pas
dit son dernier mot parce qu'elle a en
sa possession caché quelque part un
manuscrit de 320 pages stieg larsson
avait commencé à écrire le tome 4 de sa
saga millénium mystère on n'en sait rien
de ce manuscrit sinon ceux ci et ce
n'est pas une blague
l'action se déroule au canada ici
maxence bilodeau radio canada montréal